por aquí tenemos la suma de dos enteros
dos tercios más ocho enteros tres
cuartos y te encargo que pausa el vídeo
y vea si puedes llegar al resultado
correcto
muy bien es hora de que lo trabajemos
juntos y hay un montón de formas para
resolver esta suma de hecho se me
ocurren por ejemplo un par de formas
distintas que vamos a trabajar en este
vídeo así que una de ellas es reescribir
esta información que tengo aquí la voy a
escribir de nuevo aquí pero de la
siguiente manera tengo dos enteros
tercios ya esto le vamos a sumar ocho
enteros déjame ponerlo así ocho enteros
tres cuartos y seguramente estás
pensando porque lo escribí de esta
manera pero lo estoy haciendo porque
quiero ser muy claro observa que aquí
tengo la parte de las fracciones en
estos números mixtos y tengo en la parte
de los enteros en estos números mixtos y
vamos a sumar los de manera separada
ahora bien antes de empezar a sumar las
fracciones de estos números mixtos
observa que no tenemos un denominador
común tenemos diferentes denominadores
en este número mixto tengo como
denominador al 3 y en este número mixto
tengo como denominador al 4 así que
estaría muy bien encontrar un
denominador común y en el pasado hemos
visto varias veces cuando queremos sumar
fracciones con diferentes denominadores
entonces un buen denominador común es
mínimo común múltiplo en este caso vamos
a buscar el mínimo común múltiplo entre
3 y 4 y quién es ese mínimo común
múltiplo bueno pues pensemos en los
múltiplos de 4 y vamos a buscar entre
los múltiplos de 41 que también sea
múltiplo de 3 así que vamos a pensar 4
bueno 4 no es perfectamente divisible
entre 3 así que éste no 88 tampoco es
divisible perfectamente entre 3 12 12 si
en efecto éste sí es divisible
perfectamente entre 3 12 es cuatro veces
tres así que puedo reescribir
ambas fracciones con el 12 como
denominador así que vamos a escribirlo
déjame escribirlo así voy a poner aquí
dos enteros y bueno ahora voy a pasar
esta fracción en algo sobre 2
y cuánto sería este algo bueno pues
observa lo siguiente para ir de 3 a 2
tuve que multiplicar el 3 por 4 y así
llegué al 12 entonces vamos a
multiplicar también por 4 el numerador
de esta fracción por lo tanto 2 x 4
es lo mismo que 8 o puedo decir que dos
tercios es lo mismo que 8 doceavos o que
todos enteros dos tercios es lo mismo
que dos enteros 812 ambos y ahora
podemos hacer lo mismo con este de abajo
tengo ocho enteros ocho enteros y tres
cuartos va a ser lo mismo que algo entre
12 estás de acuerdo y que va a ser este
álbum bueno pues para pasar de 4 a 12
multiplique al 4 por 3 por lo tanto voy
a multiplicar este numerador también por
3 y 3 por 3
y ahora sí ahora sí podemos sumar las
ahora si podemos sumar las y que voy a
obtener
bueno pues tenemos 8 12 ambos más 9 12 a
vos eso es lo mismo que 17 12 a vos
estás de acuerdo pero espera aquí puedes
reconocer que 17 12 a vos es mayor o
igual que uno entonces esta es una
fracción impropia así que qué te parece
si mejor la reescribimos como un número
mixto y déjame ser claro la voy a quitar
de aquí y la voy a poner por acá
1712 a vos y lo voy a escribir como un
número mixto esto es lo mismo que en un
entero 5 12 a vos y como obtuve esto
bueno pues recuerda que 12 cabe una vez
en 17 y luego sobran 5 más por lo tanto
17 12 a vos es lo mismo que uno
05 12 años una vez que ya tengo esto voy
a poner el 5 12 a vos en la parte de las
fracciones de nuestro resultado o en el
lugar de las fracciones justo aquí y
este 1 lo voy a reagrupar y lo voy a
poner en la columna de los números
enteros para así poderlo sumar y ahora
simplemente puedo sumar uno más 2 que es
3 3 + 8 es 11 por lo tanto voy a obtener
11 enteros 11 enteros 5 12 años ahora
bien hay otras formas de sumar y obtener
el mismo resultado por ejemplo pudimos
haberlo hecho de la siguiente manera
tomarnos este número mixto que tengo
aquí y pasarlo como una fracción
impropia y bueno también tomar este
número mixto que tengo aquí y también
convertirlo en una fracción impropia y
después sumarlas es decir 2 enteros 8
doceavos eso es exactamente lo mismo que
bueno 2 es lo mismo que 24 doceavos
8 12 a vos eso serían 32 12 años
entonces este número mixto que tengo
arriba me va a quedar como 32 12 a vos
visto como una fracción impropia y
después y después puedo escribir este
número mixto que tengo abajo como cuánto
bueno 8
es lo mismo que 8 por 12 es 96 entonces
me quedarían 96 doceavos más 9 12 ambos
y eso es lo mismo que 105 12 ambos
esta es la fracción impropia que
corresponde a este número mixto al
número mixto de abajo y bueno si todo
esto te parece un poco confuso revisa
los vídeos de lacan academil sobre cómo
convertir números mixtos en fracciones
impropias o viceversa y bueno ahora
puedo continuar sumando estas dos vamos
a sumar estas dos y que voy a obtener
bueno 32 doceavos más 105 doceavos 32
más 105 es 137 137 12 a vos estás de
acuerdo y bueno sí ahora queremos
reescribir esto como un número mixto lo
que podemos decir es que 12
cuántas veces caben 137 bueno 12 cabe 11
veces en 137 porque 11 por 12 es lo
mismo que 132 y entonces nos quedan 5
nos restan 5 así que esto me va a dar 11
enteros
doceavos este número mixto es lo mismo
que esta fracción en propia y observa
que llegamos a la misma respuesta puedes
llegar a la respuesta de cualquier
manera y tal vez pienses que la primera
forma es la más sencilla porque no
tienes que tratar con estos números muy
grandes como el 32 o como el 105 o como
el 137 y con la primera forma es un poco
más inmediato
dices 812 a vos más 912 a vos es lo
mismo que 1712 a vos pero 1712 a vos
cuando lo reescribimos nos dan un entero
512 a vos y entonces un entero 512 a vos
más dos más 8 eso es lo mismo que 11
enteros 512 a vos